first off can you tell me about
approaching your aunt and basically
asking for her blessing to write the
screenplay I was really worried about I
don't know I guess I was worried she'd
say no and I called her up and I said I
have this idea and I pitched her the
story and she said why that case say I
argued bigger cases I read cases in
front of the Supreme Court landmark
cases why is that the one you want to
argue you want to write about and I said
well cuz it's the only one that you and
uncle Martin ever argued together right
for me this has always been a movie
about a marriage it's the two of them
fighting in court for what they also you
know figured out how to live at home and
that really quality so once I told her
that she said that's how you think you'd
like to spend your time
did you ever toy around with the idea of
taking this to like the epic extent and
covering the entire course no never
never not was I generally speaking I
don't enjoy those episodic movies have
like the cradle to to broken ribs so I
didn't that was not a story to tell and
then what was it like when you found out
who was going to be cast in this movie -
what did Felicity bring out of your
script that maybe you didn't even
anticipate before oh please portrayal is
it's just personal she's uncanny she's
incredible
and and and and you know Ruth is a very
very particular
alchemy to her personality especially
when you know were sort of outside of
the limelight because she's steely and
precise and tends as you think she is
but it's all undergirded by this joy and
this optimism and Felicity captures that
so beautifully to answer the other
question you asked of what did she bring
to it that I didn't even recognize until
she taught it to me it was how Ruth Ruth
does this thing now I can't unhear it
when I taught her that when she when she
gets emotional she leads into her
Brooklyn accent and then when she sort
of recovers that poise that she's so
famous for she stops and then you know
and she gets emotional again she and
then there are certain words that it
comes out when she talks about New York
her mother she becomes more emotional
and if she leans into the Brooklyn
accent and Felicity captured that so
beautifully she plays that accent like
it's a harp it's incredible what about
the family dynamic - because especially
this year I saw the RBG documentary I
have read up quite a bit about Ruth
Bader Ginsburg before but I think it was
the family element and in particular how
the three of them include
Jane I'm great and it was just such a
rich dynamic that I don't think we
really get to hear about that all that
much no usually the families pushed
aside
but you couldn't write the Ginsberg's
and and pushed aside the family because
you know you don't get a Ruth Bader
Ginsburg without a Martin Ginsburg and
by the way you don't get a Martin
Ginsburg without a Ruth Bader Ginsburg
they they were such a neither one of
them is perfect but the two of them
together were perfect and then putting
Callie's Fanny in between the two of
them and it's just by her bite she goes
toe to toe oh good she's just she has
this intelligence of the strength of
this and she's great she's seen a lot of
her this year and I can't wait to see
more after we're gonna see a lot more of
her I think there's also curious about
your take on finding that balance
between creating an entertaining piece
of cinema but also staying true to the
fact it could be a tough thing to
balance sometimes it can't be um you
know luckily the stakes were high from
the start and so that gives you that
sort of that drive to keep watching the
movie and she's such an intriguing
character there's there's very little in
the story that isn't true there's some
stuff in the story that isn't accurate
but everything that's inaccurate serves
the truth mm-hmm and can you tell me a
little bit about what you took from this
whole process because so many people are
gonna see this movie and for me for
instance I walk out feeling just
empowered and really striving for
whatever I want to achieve but great for
you in particular what did you walk away
from this process with that extra
motivation maybe something you didn't
expect you know I walked away from I'll
tell you I know how to quit that since
you asked I Ruth Bader Ginsburg changed
the country but she did it by convincing
people to agree with her not by
destroying the people who disagreed with
her and that's what I walk away from
this move is this hope that maybe we can
get back to that because we seem really
bad at it these days and I don't know
where are the country goes if we don't
find it again I'm gonna cut that
soundbite out and play it to myself
every single morning ideally you
complain to other people as well that's
you